in this video we will study about the
process of glycolysis the work like ah
lysis is made up of two words the word
glyco means glucose and the word lysis
means break down the glycolysis is a
metabolic pathway that involves systemic
breakdown of glucose to produce energy
and the glycolysis takes place in the
cytosol of the cells first we will have
an overview about this process and then
we will study about the various
reactions involved in glycolysis of one
molecule of glucose which is a six
carbon compound is broken down into two
molecules of pyruvate which is a three
carbon compound and in this conversion
energy is released in the form of ATP
and NADH the pyruvate formed is further
utilized in various energy producing
pathways that produces more energy the
process of glycolysis takes place in two
phases in the first phase the glucose is
first converted into two molecules of
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate since this
conversion involves addition of
phosphate the first phase actually uses
energy instead of producing it in the
second phase the
glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate is converted
into pyruvate and it is in the second
phase energy is actually produced
now let's look at the various reaction
involved in the glycolysis so it all
begins with a molecule of glucose that
enters the cytosol and the first
reaction that takes place is conversion
of glucose to glucose 6-phosphate the
enzyme that catalyzes this reaction is
called hexokinase the word hexo means
six denoting the six carbon compound
glucose and the kinases are a group of
enzymes that catalyze the
phosphorylation reactions so the enzyme
hexokinase transfers a molecule of
phosphate from ATP to glucose and
converts glucose to glucose 6-phosphate
in this reaction ATP is converted into a
molecule of ADP hence it utilizes one
molecule of ATP next the glucose
6-phosphate is converted into its isomer
the fructose 6-phosphate by the enzyme
isomerase this is a simple rearrangement
reaction in the next step the fructose
6-phosphate is converted to fructose 1 6
bisphosphate that is addition of another
phosphate group as the first carbon of
the fructose ring this reaction is
catalyzed by the enzyme phosphoric token
is another kinase enzyme which transfers
a group of phosphate from ATP to
fructose 6-phosphate and again ATP is
converted into adp hence another ATP is
utilized in the reaction next the
fructose 1 6 bisphosphate is split into
two molecules the
glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate and
dihydroxyacetone phosphate these both
are 3 carbon compounds and the enzyme
that catalyzes this reaction is called
aldolase these are reactions compose the
first phase of the glycolysis and as you
can see energy is actually utilized in
this process in the form of two ATP's
the two compounds
glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate and
dihydroxyacetone phosphate are actually
isomers and can be interconverted into
each other by the enzyme isomerase but
since the glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate is
further utilized in the process of
glycolysis the equilibrium of this
isomerization reaction is always towards
the glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate also keep
in mind that every molecule of glucose
is split into two molecules
every reaction of the second phase
happens twice and produces twice uh
products in the next reaction that
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate is converted
to 1 3 bisphosphoglycerate this involves
addition of a phosphate group at the
first position of the phosphoglycerate
the enzyme that catalyzes this reaction
is the glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate
dehydrogenase and in this reaction
nicotinamide adenine dinucleotide which
is the coenzyme is reduced to NADH which
is further utilized in the electron
transport chain to produce more energy
also this reaction utilizes a molecule
of inorganic phosphate the 1 3
bisphosphoglycerate is converted to 3
phosphoglycerate by the enzyme
phosphoglycerate kinase this kinase
enzyme transfers the phosphate group at
the first position of phosphoglycerate
to adenosine diphosphate and in this
process a molecule of ATP is generated
next the 3 phosphoglycerate is converted
to 2-phosphoglycerate
this is a simple rearrangement reaction
that happens with the help of the enzyme
phosphoglycerate mutase next the
2-phosphoglycerate is converted to
phosphoenolpyruvate
the enzyme involved is in a lace and
magnesium ions are also utilized in this
reaction in the final step of the
glycolysis the phosphoenol pyruvate is
converted to pyruvate by the enzyme
pyruvate kinase the phosphate group at
the phosphoenolpyruvate is transferred
to ADP and converted to ATP this all
composes the second phase of the
glycolysis and as you can see energy is
produced in the second phase of the
glycolysis now let's first look at the
net reaction of glycolysis and then we
will understand it in brief
we have one molecule of six carbon
glucose that splits into two molecules
of three carbon compound pyruvate there
is a net utilization of only two ATP's
since four ATP's are used in the second
phase but two ADP's are also produced in
the first phase there is a net use of
only two ATP's two molecules of
inorganic phosphate are utilized in this
step two nicotinamide adenine
dinucleotide are reduced to nadh
molecules in conversion of
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate to 1 3
bisphosphoglycerate this was a brief
overview of the process of glycolysis I
hope you find this video helpful thank
you so much for watching this video like
our channel on YouTube for all the
upcoming videos and make sure to LIKE
our channel on Facebook for flashcards
and upcoming notifications